[Music]
hey folks
welcome to our unity 2020 campfire early
morning edition
i have the honor of sitting with
governor jesse ventura
who is joining us this morning to talk
about the unity
ticket the state of america and all
sorts of related
concepts welcome governor ventura
thank you my pleasure great to be here
i'm uh i should announce
right away i'm computer illiterate and
i've never owned a cell phone
and i've now made it my life's mission
to never own a cell phone
i figure if i live another 15 or 20
years
i can put it on my grave and i might be
the only one that can do it
you're going to be the last holdout i
respect that i have to say
yeah they are a faustian bargain at best
uh so what i'm gonna do is i am going to
light a couple of candles here
as part of our metaphor of campfire
while i explain to our new viewers
that fires have played a very important
role
in human history and prehistory people
have gathered around
fires in the evening as their eyes are
no longer capable of allowing them
to do the work of being human out in the
wild
and when times are good people celebrate
celebrate around fires
when times are not so good they discuss
what's going wrong and what might be
done about it
that's why we've used this metaphor so
anyway i have a little candle for
each of us here governor ventura
and um so what we are going to do is
have a conversation about the state of
the country
and what we might be doing about it
so let me say a few other things
introducing
you you were a navy seal
in vietnam is that correct well actually
i
in my day we were two units we were the
underwater demolition teams as well as
the navy seals
and uh when i deployed my first
deployment i was a member of the last
underwater demolition team udt12 who
deployed to vietnam as an entire team
in february of 71 and then they i won't
go into detail because a lot of that's
classified
but then they broke us down in the
different type of deployments but
you all go shoot through the same
training i went through clsbi
so you're completely interchangeable one
unit works a little bit more in the
water
while the other unit works a little bit
more on land
and am i right that the skills involved
in underwater demolition are also useful
in renegade politics uh
i guess with the art of survival you
could throw that in there and you never
quit
you know when you go through buds
training and brings underwater
demolition shield training it's about a
half a year long
in comparison the elite army airborne
training is three weeks and buds
training is 26 weeks
and so uh it's the hardest training
known to the united states military
we're probably the only unit
that truly has the respect of the united
states marine corps
interesting well um i should say there
is an interesting concentration
of i believe it would be fair to say
special forces
folks in our movement and people favored
by our movement admiral mcraven
uh nate boyer dan crenshaw
jocko willink all of these names are
related to
unity 2020 in one way or another so you
are
in uh a group of elite special forces
people associated with
recapturing the white house for the
american public which
uh i would imagine is a
something that we share a belief that
that has to be done if we are to
to right the ship of state
go ahead i would agree with that that uh
you know right now
i question our leadership a great deal
uh it that is a tough job i mean let's
not deny it being head
president of the united states is no
walk in the park
you know i was a governor and being a
head of a state
is difficult and and i can only imagine
when you're
the head guy of 50 states what you have
to deal with on a daily basis but it's
something that
that requires your total concentration
uh i don't think you should be playing
golf on the weekends when you have a
pandemic loose in the country
and things of that nature i think that
you should be putting in
40 to 60 hour work weeks at a minimum
yes i think it's a job no
rational person could want what one
hopes is that somebody who feels
the feels the call will take the office
out of a sense of duty and that seems to
me a much better
model at the moment what we seem to have
is a system
in which uh people with uh unbridled
ambitions seem to end up in this office
and it has not served us well
well i i was told and this was
interesting by an
outlaw biker are you familiar with one
percenters outlaw bikers
uh why don't you give us a refresher a
one percenters
the outlaws the bikers that people fear
and you know i was with some a few
months ago
and one of them said something very
profound to me
he said you need to be the next
president and i said why is that
he said because you're the only one that
doesn't want the job
yep yes if you think about that for a
moment
and this coming from an outlaw biker
that's pretty perceptive
of stating you want the person who
doesn't want the job but feels
obligated because of his patriotism
and love and everything that he will do
the job
even though he really wouldn't make it
his first choice of
four years of employment so how familiar
are you
with the unity 2020 proposal not too
familiar
i know that they uh i i know that they
seem to want to draft someone for
president and apparently and it was news
to me
that that's apparently what happened in
the case of dwight eisenhower which i
had
no idea of and again it falls back to
our
what we're taught in school which i
think is highly
questionable today the things i'm
learning today
i'm now questioning why wasn't i taught
this in school
why didn't i know anything about this in
school
prime example that thing in tulsa
oklahoma with the black people
never once in school was i ever taught
about that major event
where the black people were slaughtered
in tulsa oklahoma
that wasn't taught in school when i went
there so
you know to me it's a case of you know
we we got to get our history in line and
start telling
the public the truth no matter how much
it hurts
the truth is what it is yes and i would
imagine
that an honorable team
at the head of our government would
view the repair or the replacement of
school with something that properly
functioned as a high priority
because as george carlin said the
purpose of school
is to make you just smart enough to
operate the machines
and it turns out actually we offshored
the machine so even that's not
necessary anymore um it's time to make
school function and
you can deduce an awful lot not from
what's taught in school but what
what's absent from the curriculum you're
quite right about that
and unfortunately we've lost the voice
of george carlin which we so
dire need today we need george carlin
back if there's any way to resurrect him
and muhammad ali
those are the two people that we need to
bring back from the dead
i agree i i i miss them both bill hicks
as well
there there are a number of people whose
help we could use at this moment
so let me tell you um about unity 2020's
proposal because it isn't really as
simple as
electing a president who's uh
feels called by patriotism to do the job
part of the problem with that as you
know as a an independent politician
you've been both a mayor and a governor
as governor you were elected in the
reform
party if my understanding is correct no
actually i was elected from the
independence party of minnesota
we then after i was elected ultimately
aligned with the reform party and then
when we realized the reform party was
not a real third-party movement it was
only the movement of ross perot
we then disenfranchised while i was
still in office and went back to being
the independence party of minnesota
no we in minnesota if you get a
candidate that gets five percent of the
vote in a statewide election
you then qualify as a major party and we
had
dean barkley ran and he got over five
percent of the minnesota vote
and so the independence party then
achieved major party status in the state
of minnesota
and what won the election for me was
they allowed me in the debates
because at the primary i was polling
nine
percent hubert humphrey skip humphrey
was at 46
and uh mayor or former senator norm
coleman was at about 33
coleman never changed through the whole
election from the
from the uh uh uh from his polling he
was always within the margin of error
humphrey dropped from 46 to 28. i went
up to 37 because also
they predicted only a 50 voter turnout
because it was a non-presidential
it turned out they were wrong 60 percent
came out
i was polling 27 the day before the
election
they didn't count on that 10 i won with
37
that is the key the key is to hit the 50
of people in this country that do not
vote you must motivate them to come out
give them a reason to do it
i did it minnesota they they told me not
to go to college campuses
they told me young people didn't vote i
told them
they've never had jessie the body before
send me to every campus you got in this
state and i did
they were sold out to the rafters and
let me brag for a moment and state the
headlines in the minneapolis paper after
i won
ventura wins sub headline
throngs of young voters provide the
margin so i
got to the young people and they put me
over the top
so uh interesting that you should say
that because
um we did polling when we started this
this endeavor we polled people who
signed up to volunteer their time so
these are people committed enough to
do more than just give us an email
address and what we found the plan
for reasons you'll see shortly when i uh
explain it the plan brought people
almost evenly from the left and the
right would be trump supporters and
would-be biden supporters but the thing
that was most heartening about it
was that a quarter of the people who
signed up to volunteer with us were not
going to vote for anybody
until they ran into unity 2020. these
were disaffected voters who are showing
up in large
numbers and that pattern has continued
we have more recent
data from people who have watched our
campfires and
participated in our our data collection
effort so um i think
one thing that is clearly true is that
party loyalists are having a hard time
figuring out how to dismiss
unity 2020 because it doesn't trigger
any of the
things that they usually use to silence
efforts
that are outside of the duopoly in other
words they usually tell you well
maybe that's a good idea but you can't
do it this year because this year is too
important and you'll spoil the election
but we don't spoil the election we've
designed the plan specifically to avoid
any possibility of that
and it seems to work but it is also true
that the parties are in no position to
lecture us on our moral obligations if
we're bringing people back into civic
life
who were so fed up that they weren't
planning to vote that's something we
should all desire and the fact that the
parties aren't interested in it
is very telling oh yeah very much so
like i said
they they count minnesota and maine
usually lead the nation and voter
turnout
we're battling maine ironically when i
was governor
the only other independent governor was
angus king from maine
so the two states that have the highest
voter per capita turnout
also were the two states that elected
independent governors
back in 1998 i got all the press
but angus actually preceded me by four
years
he was in his second four-year term when
i was entering
my first four-year term but it just
showed
you'll get the biggest voter turnout if
you have a third
choice some legitimate third choice that
people can go to
because like i said in minnesota they
have they projected a 50
voter turnout it turned out to be 60. i
was polling 27
in a three-way race i won with 37
so it was that 10 that they did not
count on
that showed up at the polls you know
when we knew we were going to win it
we have we have also same day
registration here which makes it great
we found out the morning of the election
at the university of minnesota
the lines were around the block to vote
and that's that morning when we said by
god we're going to win this thing
because there were mo and they also
stated more people were
lining up to register than we're lining
up to vote
so i knew they're not registering to
vote for a democrat or republican newly
they're registering because someone else
has entered the game
and i happen to be the fortunate one who
did that
yes uh you can tell that the parties
aren't really interested
in governing because they aren't really
interested
in how many people are involved in the
process they're only interested in
whether or not they can freeze out other
efforts and whether or not they
can win power that they can then sell to
the highest bidder
so an awful lot of us have recognized
that that process
can't possibly work in the nation's
interest the big thing for me is this
about them
if you watch the democrats and
republicans both of them
they put their party first the party
comes before the country
look at the examples of that you've
shown right now with mitch mcconnell
just blocking anything they can do to
president trump
so trump has mcconnell in his back
pocket they can't do a thing to him he
can run him up
out there do anything he basically wants
and as long as the senate won't convict
him of anything
he's free to do it and that's the big
problem they put their party first
then who comes second they're big donors
the big corporations the people that
give them the big money
they're the second on the chain who's
third on the list
well third is probably their own
personal viewpoint may come in at that
point number three
and where do the people stand i would
give us fourth
but i may be wrong something could sneak
in and we could
actually be fifth i haven't figured out
fourth fully yet
but we're no better than fourth right
now again
it's party first big time money donors
second
personal opinion third yeah they uh they
laugh at us behind our backs we are
um basically patsy's in their
influence peddling operation and you
know this has actually been established
now it's been scientifically studied and
the interests of the public have almost
no influence on
policy at this point and it's precisely
because the parties
have a business model that does not
involve actually
governing it's also incidentally
tearing the country apart because
they're selling us
symbolism and they're selling us uh the
demonization of other americans rather
than actually
doing their job so i'm i'm sure we're in
almost complete agreement about that if
not complete agreement but let me tell
you um
the what is making unity 2020 difficult
for the parties to dismiss
is the structure the structure involves
not electing somebody who is outside of
the parties
but drafting a team of two people one
from the left
and one from the right under an
agreement that they will govern
by consensus somebody has to be the top
of the ticket obviously
that person would be chosen by coin flip
and after four years
the uh the positions would reverse and
the president would run as vice
president
and this could go on until one party had
been president twice at which point
they'd have to be replaced by
someone new and uh the system could go
on indefinitely
so that structure a
reduces the chance of spoiling the
election to almost
zero we also have a fail-safe which is
if the
ticket cannot win at the point that the
election
is approaching we pull the plug on it
and the election reverts to its
uh prior state but it also
seems to assure people as we hoped it
would
that when decisions are made at the
level of the chief executive
that their values and interests will be
represented in the room
and that what is done will be that which
is in the public's interest
rather than special interests
and that sounds wonderful i guess i'd
piggyback on that
my best answer would be to also include
the constitution of the united states of
america
because it seems to me today the two
parties
that it's a worthless document that is
there only in name only
nobody follows that nobody goes by the
rules of it
i mean how many wars are we involved in
now
and yet we've never declared a war since
world war
ii now it bothers me tremendously today
because i'm a vietnam veteran
but technically i'm a war criminal
i served my country but i'm a war
criminal why
because the united states never did
actually declare war in vietnam
so therefore the geneva convention
doesn't apply to any of us
uh we are all war criminals because our
own government and politicians
wouldn't declare the war my position's
simple i'm very anti-war
and you'd have to convince me greatly
that that the united states is in dire
trouble and has to defend itself but on
the flip side
if the congress did i want the congress
to declare war
so that then as a president you can
carry out that declaration
but when they don't declare war then it
isn't a war
and that's what we're involved in today
so i would add
to you the constitution of the united
states needs to be followed
it's not just a document there to look
good
it's the law of the land and it's about
time we get elected officials that pay
attention
to the law of the land well i would
certainly agree with you i think uh the
constitution
is a spectacular document
i must confess i think there are
elements of it that i think
are out of date and that's no uh that's
not a bad reflection on the founding
fathers they couldn't possibly have
understood
the world that that document would have
to function in but
at the moment we don't even uh treat the
spirit of it
um with any sort of reverence which you
know your point about
uh the executive declaring war by
playing word games and calling things
police actions and the like
that's obviously a violation of the
spirit of the document
and yes it is about time that we
we stopped behaving that way it's beyond
the spirit
the document says clearly congress shall
declare war
it does the spirit involves there it's
in black and white
well i agree that this is what i'm
saying is we have violated the spirit of
the document
um and fights you with your answer
no i i appreciate it and you know i'm
quite disturbed about the
uh abandonment of the core principles
there in fact
you know you can make a strong argument
that the ndaa
of 2012 um violated
or at least sets up the violation of
every
uh one of the rights enumerated in the
bill of rights except possibly
your third amendment right so anyway i'm
i'm
very disheartened that we have treated
the document so badly
and let me add this there are things in
in the constitution that should be
changed
i'll give you one right now the
electoral college
let's get rid of the electoral college
it's an elitist system
it's totally outdated the only reason it
was in place
was because at that time you didn't have
communication
and everyone had to ride on horseback to
washington
my answer to that is when's the last
time somebody went on horseback to
washington
and the point is then you hear the
argument well everyone will forget about
the little states because they'll only
care about the big states with the
people
i got news for you if i'm running for
president and i've given the option to
campaign in california or montana
which one you think i'm going to i'm
going to the one with all the electoral
votes not the one with two
or three so that's a false argument
when they say that the candidate won't
pay attention to the little state
they're not going to anyway any more
than they have to they're going to go
where the masses are
and to me how can you have an electoral
system
where somebody who gets the most votes
loses
i mean that doesn't happen for mayor
governor senator congress even
dog catcher if you vote on that
the guy who a dire girl who gets the
most votes
wins except the presidency
now that's utterly ridiculous in my
opinion
well uh you know this is not going to be
popular and
the fact is what i think about this
doesn't make any difference because
i'm not running for office right this is
just one man's opinion but
um there are arguments both ways the
current instantiation of the electoral
college
is an abomination the fact is it's been
captured by the parties and they use it
as a mechanism to ensure
that nothing that they don't like
happens at the level of presidential
politics it's one more mechanism
for ensuring that they remain in control
that said
the idea of a body that could prevent
a catastrophe in the event that
something happened
strikes me as potentially positive as
long as
it left the will of the public intact as
it functioned now
i agree with you there is a perverse
incentive to visit big states and pay
attention to them
um rather than states that are sparsely
populated
so there's a lot to talk about with
respect to what the electoral college
should be and certainly there's no
defense for what it is
but um but nonetheless it's it's
it's a complex complex issue
i don't think so i think it's very
simple
he who he or she who gets the most votes
deserves to win
i believe that should generally be the
case anything else is bogus
anything else is bogus look at for all
the years
the delegates didn't even have to vote
the way their state wanted them to
your state could vote for one candidate
but you as a delegate could go there and
vote for a different candidate what kind
of nonsense was that
then they're just cleaning that up now
in some states
it's still not that way in other states
so you've got an elitist
group that chews it so truthfully when
you vote for president
your vote don't count because he isn't
elected by you he or she isn't elected
by you
they're elected by the electoral college
so that that may be the biggest reason
we're talking about why people don't
vote today
because they know their vote is
meaningless
well um we agree that the current form
of the electoral college is a tremendous
problem and an obstacle
to democracy i guess the question is do
we need a fail-safe or don't we
um but anyway maybe a conversation for a
different time
for that mother day yep all right so um
what do you think about a uh a power
sharing arrangement where right and left
engage
in patriotic decision making on behalf
of the public
well i think it sounds good on paper but
i think getting it to actually work
will be will be the true challenge of it
i mean it might look good and people
might talk it up great
and say oh yeah we're all gonna we're
all gonna sing kumbaya by the fire now
but will that be the reality of the
situation
dealing with politicians i don't think
so
well we're not talking about dealing
with politicians we're talking about
dealing with people who have been chosen
by the unity movement for their ability
to honor that agreement
uh you're among them did they choose the
right person
well they've chosen six people uh who
can be composed
into nine tickets we haven't yet had our
vote
so we don't know what ticket it is that
we are uh going to draft but
um you're a new experiment it is a new
experiment
and we got to see what happens when you
throw the dirty pants in the washer
yep so if you found yourself clean or do
they come out still
dirty right uh yeah i guess it depends
how dirty they are but uh
i'm i'm a fan of the idea that if the
right people
are chosen and i believe six
excellent people have been chosen by our
membership that this plan can work
because
one of the components that is required
of our candidates
is that they be patriotic right the
other two
they have to be capable and they have to
be courageous and i believe
if you put two capable courageous
patriots together and you say
the nation needs you that they will do
the right thing that those
characteristics are
sufficient to ensure it i hope you're
right
excellent all right so if you found
yourself
in uh the white house let's say as part
of
a partnership and you need to be
hypothetical now i don't want to lose my
job or my health care by them saying i'm
running
so verbally right now
i do not want to lose at this time my
health care or my job which i would lose
both
if i run at this moment so this is
completely hypothetical
it's a thought experiment nobody has
been drafted
all right so in this thought experiment
let's say you found yourself
in the white house elected through i
don't want to call it a third party
because i don't think of unity 2020 as a
third party but it is
uh outside of the two-party system if
you were to be elected
uh as part of that structure and you
were faced
with a congress that was composed
of members of the duopoly do you think
you'd be able to
work with them to get things done well i
already did it
you're talking to the only guy that you
got on your list of six who's already
did it
when i was elected in minnesota i was by
myself
we have no independence we did gain one
uh
one democrat got booted up north a great
guy
and i fought for him and got him a
minority uh
position so they had to honor him as a
minority representative he was our only
one halfway through but getting back on
track
when i got elected i had a a democratic
senate and a republican house right
for the first three years whoever i
sided with generally prevailed because
it was two to one
for the first let me say that again the
first
three years i can tell you exactly what
will happen
been there done that third year is when
the democrats and republicans jumped in
bed together
they started singing kumbaya by the fire
together
reunited the state of minnesota's
democratic and republican parties
to oppose who me the common sense
middle now they're in bed against me in
my third year
my job as governors to submit the budget
i submitted the budget
they declined it they came back with
their own budget
not the governor's budget their budget
it was
fiscally irresponsible i vetoed it
they sent it back a second they overrode
my veto
sent it back to me a second time i
vetoed it again which was all that i
could do
they overrode me a second time and uh
that budget went into effect well they
thought they were gonna get me with that
budget
because i'd now have to operate under so
that was one of the reasons
as well as multiple others why i didn't
seek re-election
i didn't want to operate on their budget
because i knew it was fiscally
irresponsible
to do so lo and behold i was right
what happened after i left office that
they were banking on a strong economy
they were rolling the dice
that that was going to happen not good
policy fiscally
to gamble with the people's money they
failed
minnesota had a five billion dollar
deficit they had to deal with
why because the democrats and
republicans
teamed up and got political together to
overrule
the seated governor who who brought
forward a fiscally responsible budget
but they didn't want none of that they
were gonna exercise their power
so see i've been there and done that i
know exactly how it would work
if i were elected president
hypothetically
it would take me three years to unite
the democrats and republicans back in
bed together
because the thing they fear most is a
third entity
they fear that more than anything else
they talk about
they don't want a third entity in the
game
and when that entity comes into the game
rest assured within four hours
four years the dems and repubs will be
back
in total unity you'll see how wonderful
they get along
so that is how in one way you save the
nation
well i mean that's not a very hopeful
story at some level because uh
the democrats and republicans uniting to
thwart the governors uh
want the truth don't you i sure do there
it is
so that's what you're gonna deal with
well if i can push back a little bit
they do
have a third entity at the moment donald
trump
was not exactly a republican and he
seems to have
decapitated the republican party and
taken it over
successfully so uh while
you might have imagined that the
democrats and republicans
would have um conspired against him
that's not what we saw we saw something
else so
i'm not sure that the pattern you
suggest which
i do believe is real and likely is
the only pattern we can see other
phenomena
i disagree with you because the moment
donald trump
donald trump came to visit me after i
won
donald trump also used my playbook to
get elected
but the moment donald trump declared he
was a republican
that ended any likeness to me he became
a republican
when he entered the republican primary
he was not a third entity then
he was a republican just like bernie
sanders
bernie likes to tell everybody he's an
independent
and yet i find bernie is nothing more
than a democrat
because i approached bernie sanders when
he was in 2016
and i was going to break my cardinal
rule i actually thought about endorsing
him
i went down and called his people went
down he wouldn't give me the time of day
when he finally did he gave me 30
seconds in a hallway
and i asked him one question i said
senator sanders
if you lose to secretary clinton will
you support a party movement or will you
yourself run as a third candidate
he looked at me and says no i will 100
support secretary clinton
i walked out of the building knowing
he's nothing but a democrat
he's just masking as an independent he
isn't truly an independent
he's a democrat and so getting back on
touch
trump became a republican when he ran
for that office
you're not going to tell me that they're
a third entity when they join a party
and run under that party's label
from snow they are now part of the
republican party and they are part of
the democratic party
they are not independents neither was
donald trump
the only thing he did different instead
of going to fundraisers he did what i
did he went to rallies
where do you think he got that idea from
i went to rallies on college campuses
all minnesota
and all that trump watched and he saw
how it worked
while hillary was there collecting big
money donald trump was out meeting the
people like jesse ventura
well i i see a big difference between uh
sanders and
trump i think there were reflections of
the same frustration
and therefore uh you know they told us
something about the state of the
electorate in 2016.
but effectively trump muscled in
on the republicans action and
sanders was an independent but he has
played party loyalists which i must say
is where he lost me um i i was a
supporter
in 2016 of sanders and at the point
he endorsed clinton i had the sense that
this is now a dead end
and uh i i wish i didn't have to say
that because i as much as i disagree
with sanders about
policy i greatly respect his ability to
exist as an independent
uh inside the duopoly
and frankly i think whatever it is that
goes on inside the democratic party
reflects a level of control that the
people outside need to understand
it has controlled its primaries so that
entities that believe something
different you know andrew yang
tulsi gabbard uh bernie sanders are all
shut down early in favor of these sort
of
dnc standard bearers and
they won't survive our uh
are continuing down that path
well you know i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna make excuses democrats and how
they run their operation or the
republicans who run theirs
but to me unless you're running with an
eye
in front of your name as an independent
belong to those two parties
and all the people that bernie and trump
and all them ran with the party
designation
by their names so essentially they those
parties to become their candidates
and so uh you know you and i may beg to
differ on that a little bit but
to me an independent is an independent
through
you don't join one party because it's
politically advanced advantageous for
you at the moment
and then uh you know and which is what
trump
in my opinion when he joined the
republicans
he he wasn't me anymore he wasn't trying
to do what i wanted to do
and bernie the same way bernie's a
democrat he might have gone independent
and have that by his name but the
reality is he's a democrat
well so uh i think maybe this is the
the very important thing that we have to
discuss with each other then because
your point about independent i resonate
with but i don't think it goes far
enough because there are too many
ways to be independent and that in in
effect the unity movement
is about bringing all of those who have
recognized
that we have a critical problem
together on the basis that the thing
that should unite all of us
is the well-being of the nation and the
interests
of citizens and so the unity movement is
really not about being independent from
the parties it is about
joining together to overthrow them and
i see that as the only path forward and
you may be right
i don't necessarily sit in and say that
my way is any better than anything all
i'll say is good luck
well because well because you're you're
you're first of all you're going to get
infiltrated badly by the two parties
they're going to send opportunity
and uh they're going to disrupt things
and they're going to make it as horrible
as they possibly can for all of you
in in that in that situation because it
remembers
always fair and love war and politics
they're the dirtiest players out there
and it's the dirtiest business out there
and when you're done being involved in
the business you know what you feel like
you need a good hot shower
just being part just being part of what
happened which i've done
for what now eight years i've been
elected uh
mayor i beat both parties when i was
elected mayor of brooklyn park
both it was a nonpartisan election the
two leaders of the state of minnesota
co-signed a letter
and sent it to every citizen in brooklyn
park
calling me the most dangerous man in the
city
well i won 67 percent of 53
against a 20-year incumbent endorsed by
both major political parties
so you know if you want to bring the
dems
together if they're willing to do that
that's a wonderful thing
but i challenge you i want to see the
demon repub
singing kumbaya together you know for
the country because
i just don't see them uh going
that direction oh no i'm not suggesting
that we unify the democrats
and republicans i think those two
parties are beyond
redemption i want to to unify the people
who understand that
that everybody who understands that and
believes
in the nation has an interest in joining
together
in order to break their stranglehold on
power that's the point so
that's what unity is about it's the
unity of the people outside the duopoly
and
those inside who have ears to hear
that there is a problem right those
people will all very naturally
uh want to do whatever is necessary to
eliminate that corrupt
uh duopoly power structure because it
works against the interests of of the
people and it works against the
long-term interests of the nation
and you're going to need to look at this
as probably a
at least minimum of a 10-year
a 10-year thing must happen because i
don't believe
it and i don't see it happening fully
integrated
it'll take at least 10 years to break
the stranglehold
uh to fully break it it might there's a
reason that we're starting
with the office of president because i
believe the office of president
has the greatest power you know the the
bully pulpit as they were
it's like when the mafia leader said if
you're gonna kill john kennedy you cut
off the head of the dog not the tail
so
kennedy aficionado i've studied his
murder for
most of my adulthood i find it extremely
interesting reading
it's a it's a it's a fascinating
event and uh we were trying to explain
the complexity of it to our children at
dinner the other day
because uh it whatever it is that
happened
haunts the nation to this day it's
almost like things stopped making sense
in 1963 and they have never gone back to
making sense
sir you are in my opinion exactly
correct
you and i sit together on that we have
not been the same country
since the coup d'etat took place in 63.
and you notice i called it a coup d'etat
i did notice that
so you mentioned that one of the things
the unity movement should expect
is infiltration and i don't think it's
just infiltration
we you know at the very initial
conversations that we had
as we formed the movement we talked
about the fact that we knew that that
was coming
and we also knew that other weapons
would be brought to bear against us
this week we have seen this uh happen in
spectacular form where
twitter suspended our
twitter our official twitter account
suspended the account
of volunteers that are part of our
organization
and they may be the most interesting
thing
is they they
triggered or installed some mechanism
that when you attempt to tweet a link to
our website this is not twitter this is
off-site where we distribute information
about our movement if you attempt to
tweet it it will not allow the tweet to
go out it gives you a warning
that the content is understood to be
potentially harmful
so this strikes me as an absolutely
egregious abuse of power
on twitter's part and it basically
indicates that they are aware
of the threat that a unity movement that
holds no truck with these parties poses
to the influence that they unfairly have
over government
well take that as a badge of honor take
that you're getting their attention
i i would love to add to this you're
falling into the same thing do you
remember my
show piercy theory uh i have to tell you
i don't i think i saw it okay that's
fine but i did a show called conspiracy
on tv
where we covered a lot of the
conspiracies and we were going to do it
telling both sides
but a lot of them deal with the
government and when the government
involved they're not going to cooperate
so we ended up just telling the
conspiracy side
and then we allow the people to decide
on their own well
what i'm getting back to is you're gonna
get pushed back because
you know you cannot get my conspiracy
theory shows
anywhere on the internet today they wipe
them
uh what's his name the disc jockey in
chicago i forget his name uh
off the top of my head big disc jockey
there he had all the shows he came home
from work one day went to put one in
they were wiped off his computer
and so the government you cannot get my
conspiracy theory shows
anymore to watch and to show the things
that i showed harp the thing up in
alaska
and and all the other well i showed the
internment camps
and i got read off on the floor of
congress and they
tried to turn over to the uh
anti-defamation league
you know because i made the comparison
and showed a photo of the ones in
germany to the ones we're building
and they looked identical league never
even contacted me i think they looked at
the pictures and said he's right
you know so bear in mind they'll come
after you
with guns if they've already come out
you can't get my shows
that i did and a lot of them showed some
pretty
you know i got read off on the floor of
congress by senator cohen
my hope is and i think this is already
beginning
to happen is that you know we know they
will come after us and we know
that based on the fact that honorable
governance
would uh completely restructure who the
winners and losers are
that all of the current winners are
liable to uh
to oppose it so basically um we are
expecting
a huge amount of power to be arrayed
against us
uh as we show signs of of having the
potential to actually change things
but as that power comes after us
it reveals the importance of this in
other words
it's flack over the target and to the
extent that people are paying attention
and they notice
that we are facing these things they
will come to understand
why it is that the movement has to exist
and why they should join it so um
we can't avoid it i think we just have
to to
lean into the fact that uh goliath's ire
is uh an indication that this must be
done
and look at it this way the more they
come after you
if they fear you so if they're ignoring
you
you're not having an impact so if they
if they're focusing on you then clearly
you're having
it look at it from that perspective too
yes i i don't think they're afraid of
our winning yet i believe they should be
more
afraid of it but i believe that they are
uh angered over the fact that we say in
very plain terms that they are an
influence peddling racket
and much of their power derives from the
fact that we speak about them as if
they're actually interested in
governance
and the parties are clearly not
interested in governance they're
interested
in capturing power and selling it to the
highest bidder and frankly anybody who's
paying attention can see that
so if we say it out loud it frustrates
them because
it it reveals what they're up to it's
you know we're pulling back the curtain
at some point they will recognize that
the frustration
and anger that they have created in
people
is going to to bite them and it's going
to usher them
out of power uh hopefully
enough to save the nation just make sure
when you pull back the curtain
there's an audience there to see it
all right well that's a an excellent
concept i like it
uh can you put any flesh on that bones
how do you do that
do you want that no i'm sorry i liked
your advice
when you pulled back well what i mean is
what i mean is this
getting the amer i'll be blowing the
american people off their ass
enough to pay attention you know again
you got 50 of americans that don't
vote and i sit in my head going
how can you not vote when the government
takes half your money
you go to work 40 day 40 hours a week
the government takes out half of me when
you do that
shouldn't you pay attention to who's
taking your livelihood and your money
and yet you got american people that
don't care
they just lives don't bother me as long
as it's smooth
as long as my life isn't interrupted
it's all okay
but see now their lives have been in
iraq they actually
are being asked to wear masks and we
can't even get people to do that
we can't even get american people to
guard their fellow amends
wear a freaking mask and i use my mother
as an example my mom
spent her entire adult life wearing a
mask
she was head neurosurgery at north
memorial hospital in minnesota
she was in surgery all week you wear a
mask in there
these people that talk about old masks
do anything
i challenge them then the next time you
have surgery
tell the doctors and nurses they don't
have to wear masks at the surgery
you know germs okay you you don't have a
worry about them
see we can't even get people with their
own lives on the line
to wear something as simplistic as us i
mean did you see last
night they booed when they announced
that the trump thing
that masks are required the crowd
erupted and booze
that's who you're dealing with here now
you're dealing with the public
that that and you're i don't know maybe
you're giving them more
credit for intelligence than me you know
maybe that's the problem you believe
they have more intelligence
than what i i'm dumbfounded over the
fact that we don't even have the self
someone
that shows me nobody's been in the
military because if you've been in the
military you know what discipline is
and you know that when you're in a
situation where you wear a mask to
pretend you protect
your fellow citizens and you're so
selfish
that you won't wear one and yet that's
what we have in america they told us by
december
70 000 people like moore are gonna die
because we won't wear a mask i'm only
saying that to say to you
good luck motivating these people well i
appreciate that
um what i would hope is that people
recognize especially people
who were not planning to vote that if
they want to wield power if they're not
voting because they know that their vote
doesn't matter
they can join us and they can matter
right away
right to the extent that they empower
the unity movement
that is going to motivate the parties
it's going to frighten them
and so if they want to wield power in
the system the way to do it
is to join forces against the parties
that have made their vote irrelevant
and it seems straightforward to me as
for reaching them
uh well apparently we are 25 of our
volunteers were not planning to vote
that tells us
something important um but you know it's
also the case that we are of course
up against a uh i don't know
how intentional it is presumably it's
somewhat intentional
but uh you know the media and the social
media platforms
are all effectively in line
uh if not because they've been uh
erected into a bulwark to prevent people
from wielding power
then because they enjoy having undue
influence and they're looking to protect
it
let me give you a quick story you'll
love to hear when i came out of office
in 2003
this is a true story i was the hottest
commodity out there i was the voice of
the independent
cnn msnbc
and fox got any more for me msnbc won
i signed a three-year contract with them
i was going to be on seven o'clock right
when
maddow is or whatever i was going to be
five nights a week
and but the guy who hired me
told me in a car and he wouldn't say who
he said he got a phone call from
washington
two very high ups who wanted to know why
they were giving me a national forum
you know after i've been the independent
governor of minnesota national forum
well guess what we set the whole show up
we're all ready to go on the air and we
get an interesting phone call
and here's the phone call is it governor
ventura
doesn't support the invasion of iraq
this was right before the invasion of
iraq
my assistant said oh no he's vehemently
opposed to it
he's a veteran he says this is vietnam
all over again
on the other end does uh new jersey know
does connecticut know about this meaning
the big headquarters
we don't know here came the big question
is there any chance he
changed his mind and my subordinate says
i don't think so this is a military
thing
on his military hat the governor he's
opposed to the iraq war
guess what my show wasn't allowed on the
air
they had just hired phil donahue that
they died
he was their highest rated show he
likewise opposed the warren iraq
he was pulled from the air now have you
ever heard of a network pulling their
top rated show and they're not even
letting me on
and it was all because they wanted no
voices out there
of opposition to the invasion of iraq
so when you think that mainstream media
out there isn't bought and sold by our
government
there's your example right there
opposing the iraq
war cost millions of dollars that i
would have made
uh with msnbc as a as a a show host on
there
how much would i be making a year if i
have
gotten the opportunity to do that but
because i had a position of
anti-war against the iraq war
it cost me and what happened they didn't
on the air but they paid me for the
whole three years
and my contract said i couldn't do any
news programs
or anything on cable or satellite
television
because i was handcuffed and tape was
put over my mouth
because i honor contracts and they paid
me the whole three years and bought my
silence
wow true story true story
yep i believe it sometimes they
need to go to war for reasons that they
know and we don't
um all right so uh thank you very much
for joining us i have a couple of
announcements
um really appreciate your willingness to
talk to us about the unity movement
and uh uh voting begins soon if you're
um part of our movement and you signed
up in time
we have let me ask something let me
throw something out for everybody
sure keep the unity movement going i'm
behind you all the way
go for it you know you'll get no
opposition from me on it and it's better
than the two choices we have now
i think your movement's outstanding but
i understand you got a long road aho
because taking on these parties is gonna
be a full-time job with overtime and you
ain't gonna get paid for it
so good luck to you good luck to the
unity part i can support you in any way
i will be happy to do so well i really
appreciate that governor ventura
your support means a lot and um uh
i also appreciate your message to our
our viewers i think they do need that
encouragement and they need to encourage
others so
people should spread the word all right
uh now two announcements i'm uh
going to ask you to sign up for our
email list especially
with the platforms opposing uh
our movement you need to sign up for the
email list in order to be able to
receive information about what we're up
to
so you can sign up for the email list at
articlesofunity.org
um you can also sign up at my twitter
account i will keep people apprised of
important developments
at brett weinstein there is a
podcast unity now run by our volunteers
which is a continuation
of themes of the campfire
and we will see you next time on the
next campfire
thanks governor ventura be well thank
you
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]